now biden and the democrats they
continue to blame everyone but
themselves for the mounting crisis
facing this country inflation is at a
fresh 40-year high as it has now been
for months and the prices of everything
you buy in every store you go to are way
higher
this is long before putin invaded gas
prices you feel the pain at the pump
heating your home this winter you're
paying a lot more than you were paying
last year but if you listen to the left
wing socialist democratic party and
their allies and press people in the
media mob it's only because of vladimir
putin the dog bites the bee stings if
you're feeling sad everything that joe
screws up blame putin take a look
i would say that since president putin
uh began his military buildup on
ukrainian borders the price of gas at
the pump in america has gone up 75 cents
no i mean you know he did not cause the
war which caused prices to surge and you
heard the president at state's going to
say putin's price hike putin's price
hike a putin price hike putin's price
hike and putin's price hike is a great
way to message it putin's gas hike i'm
going to do everything i can to minimize
putin's price hike here at home
all right of course facts truth actually
tells a very different story look at
your screen the biden administration's
own economic data shows that inflation
oh look at that it was surging well
before putin invaded ukraine gas prices
the price of used cars food beverage all
been going up since joey got into office
and well before putin launched his
bloody assault against a sovereign
country ukraine biden and every democrat
they are lying to you costs are surging
because of his failed economic and
energy policies his reckless spending
and of course his attacks always blame
the american oil and gas sector they're
actually making less money according to
foxbusiness.com
here to explain more fox business host
larry kudlow larry i just
i don't like being lied to
the putin
price hike as it relates to gas is bs we
were almost we're already almost paying
a buck 50 more a gallon everything we
buy in every store we have been paying
more for because it's been month after
month after month of 40-year high
inflation vladimir putin didn't cause
that but this is now the new talking
point
explain from your perspective
well look a couple numbers will help i
think there's a certain
inflation amnesia
going on with biden on the left uh
gasoline prices were 2.35 cents in
january of 21.
by october they were
3.31 cents up 40 percent that's before
putin put any troops on the east side of
the ukraine and as far as the world oil
price goes sean you were about 52
in january of 21 and it was 84
by october of 21. that's a 61 gain
so that's before putin showed up at all
those are huge numbers the inflation
rate consumer prices shown
less than two percent in december of uh
2020 and then it gradually surged to
three to five to seven and a half
percent before putin invaded by the way
the latest readings and we haven't seen
the peak yet the latest readings for the
cpi plus eight percent year on year
wholesale prices showing up 10
and today we got a beauty or yesterday
import prices up 11
and it's not over yet and i think you
were right the seeds were planted with
the huge big government socialist
deficit spending package of march 2021
about one year ago and then they sold
all that money uh by selling bonds and
the federal reserve bought the bonds so
the money supply is surging and it
continues to surge the fed hasn't done a
thing so we're in for a big problem but
those seeds were planted over a year ago
let me ask you about goldman sachs
they're now predicting in the next two
years as many as 11
interest rate hikes from the fed now
originally they were predicting three or
four this year
then they predicted as many as seven
this year as interest rates rise what
will that do
to the economy overall will it help with
inflation
because i think it's going to probably
hurt the economy more than anything else
even lawrence summers now
saying likelihood of a recession is
pretty high at this point and most
economists are saying the same thing
your thoughts
well i agree i thought what larry
summers wrote in the paper a couple days
ago is basically right right now we're
in stagflation all right the first
quarter is going to come in about two
percent sean but the inflation rate is
going to be about eight percent so
that's stagflation that's not going away
interest rates are probably going to go
up higher than almost anybody is
anticipating i mean look if you've got
an eight percent inflation yes actually
look
suppose you had a six percent inflation
rate the basic basic inflation rate
interest rates are going to have to go
to seven or eight percent in order to
quell that the fed's got to stop buying
bonds and they've got to stop printing
money that has not been done yet so all
these estimates from wall street or the
fed are way too low we are going to have
to see an enormous increase in interest
rates and yes that is going to lead to a
recession the middle class the working
folks are going to bear the brunt of
that their real wages are already
falling and it's going to be worse than
that
it's a tragedy because i will tell you
this sean as a proud alumnus of the
trump administration we left them with a
solid v-shaped recovery energy
independence and virtually no inflation
and in one year plus they have wrecked
the whole economic story it's a tragedy
it consumes the cpi was 1.4 percent now
it's 7.9 there's your inflation if we
use the old method back in the carter
years uh inflation would be at 16
percent if we calculated calculated it
using that old method larry kudlow good
to see you thank you